hi I'm James Robert I'm a designer at
IBM design here in Austin Texas I'm
going to be doing a day in the life for
free code camp it's 8:30
I needed a head out so I can stop by the
gym before work and sorry about the mess
I just got married to awesome person all
right let's go and when I say go to the
gym I mean goes a chick-fil-a for the
breakfast so I'm walking into the office
now
it's a giant campus actually iBM is not
the only person here but what's really
funny is IBM originally built this
campus either in the 60s or 70s and it's
right north of it was on the outskirts
of Austin when they built it and there
really wasn't anything else here and
since then now it's the now the largest
outdoor mall and office space is right
across the street so all of a sudden
that's the place to be in Austin usually
the family people that work here live in
a suburb north of here and then the
people that want to be where it's at
live downtown and this is right in the
middle which is nice I'm all about the
commutes I live like five minutes down
the road from here but it's a pretty
nice campus we got basketball court sand
volleyball which I don't really use but
my favorite part is that there's just so
many restaurants in that outdoor mall
right across the street to take
advantage of for lunch so it's 9:00 a.m.
I get into the office
give my chick-fil-a but really the first
task at hand is checking the email and
the slack you think I'd have a lot of
emails but rarely anymore because all of
IBM is on slack now crazy promotion I
know right so I just have a million
slack channels and messages to check
we're celebrating our a manager recently
becoming a design principle one of our
teammates decorated her desk celebrating
projects she's worked on and now we're
all signing little notes for
okay so I've looked through all my
emails not look through all my slacks
Lots and now I'm looking through github
enterprise and public github for
whatever issues PRS that I need to look
at they github Enterprise I look for
mostly PRS for different projects on my
wider team that I'd need a review and
then on public github I look through
because one of the house chores in my
job is maintaining a lot of public repos
that really are mostly just assets for
the IBM design language or so that
includes things like icons and colors
charting library we've been trying to
get off the ground publicly and it's
kind of a half developer half designer
job because we have these build
processes that we develop to
automatically generate the assets for
every change and then on the design side
we have to actually make sure they
they're usable for when designers or
designing designs you know so that takes
about like a half hour usually as long
as there's not something crazy to look
at so right now I'm backseat coding with
Trevor one of my teammates on a
different project we're just trying to
make sure his DevOps goes smoothly for
this project he's starting so now I'm
going to do exercise for a half hour
just exploring content skeletons for
when new data and experiences loading in
and see if a vest patterns come out of
this exercise I'm just going to try to
keep going as wide as possible it was
something I started yesterday
so another projects running into bluemix
problems
but the nice thing about being in the
studio in Austin is instead of dealing
with tech support for it we're just kind
of go down to the bluemix floor and
start asking friends that work for
bluemix and they'll probably solve it in
one minute and of course they figured it
out in one minute there was no problem I
wanna just share with you the entrance
to my floor we have two special guests
that are always at the entrance we have
two of the robots from the Watson
commercial that premiered the last Super
Bowl with Carrie Fisher and they've been
here for like over a year now I guess
they're permanent guests at the studio
so I've got a good amount of time left
before lunch so I'm going to add a some
search functionality that that a
teammate wanted for one of their
experiences just so they could search
between the different users to find them
fifteen lunch across the street Talbott
taco with the buds getting back from
lunch say hi to the robots iRobot iRobot
that robots confused alright so I'm back
from lunch I've got a little bit of time
before my first meeting of the afternoon
so I just want to give you a tour of the
austin studio real quick as fast as I
can so a lot of the this is the seventh
floor I work on eighth floor but the
seventh floor is actually full of these
open spaces where we do a lot of
workshops these workshops typically
client workshops or IBM teams coming to
Austin to do a workshop but we also do
them for where if your entry level
designer hired for IBM doesn't matter
which studio around the world you're
being deployed to you always come to
here for a three-month design boot camp
and so one of those open spaces is your
home for three months where you do a
bunch of crazy projects we also have
this medius studio where we're cranking
out a lot of digital media for people
this is all the colleges represented
here at the austin studio doesn't mean
you have to go to a to a college but
we're very well represented
this is our make lab we do a lot of
screen printing here you can and also
all sorts of projects
you can see some of the examples of the
great screen prints that happen here
back there we got a MakerBot
and then this is the 8th floor where I
work
it's a lot more actual just product
design teams so you'll see a lot more
death down here we've got a Power
Systems team proud of their hardware as
well as their digital designs
this is one of my favorite
Werner's because we members in Austin
with a a CL music festival with all the
posters of every year and then we've got
a video game cabinet
and then this piece is at one of those
crazy Microsoft hubs
I love it let me just leave a great
piece right here for everyone to see
we'll just let who happen the next
person is discover that and then this is
my little turf area I like to ask your
turf my apartment balconies so I use all
the leftover turf just at my desk so I'm
back at my computer the first thing I
want to do is we add IBM we have this
big educational program for front-end
developers called vegetation where we
get to present to each other new topics
across the whole company live so right
now I want to create a proposal for a
new one about why CSS and Jas is here to
stay and it's not just a fad it's really
exciting work especially coming off of a
high sand styled components version 2.0
just came out I love it and of course
all the submissions for a front-end
development education program have to be
on a github repo so every submission
idea is a issue itself
ah though I just finished coding at 4
p.m. today and kind of finish the day
off by hanging out with my buddy Evan
and explaining more about the skeletons
we need to design it's getting near the
end of the day one last thing I really
need to is clean my desk at IBM design
we use a lot of sticky notes and my desk
is covered in notes from this past week
so it's 5 o'clock on Memorial Day Friday
for the non Americans watching that
means we have Monday off
so everyone naturally wants to take
Friday before for vacation time so that
means there's nobody here right but
that's ok because we get to go now so
we're headed out going home gonna be
safe and do lots and lots of work over
we can happily one last thing I want to
share my favorite sign in this whole
studio we have an emergency exit door
and if you push it alarm goes off so we
never like when people push it but this
was how we improv stopping people from
pushing it